[Music]
hello everyone
uh the last five consecutive videos we
have been deriving the theory for this
classical place
in this video let us take one example to
see the application
of that rather long theory so the
example that we'll be taking up
is this rather simple looking
geometry uh where we'll be considering a
circular plate
uh which is subjected to a uniformly
distributed load
represented by this skew here and which
has
a clamped boundary all around it's a
clamped periphery
okay so what i'm going to do
is go back to the previous page where i
stopped
the previous video and copy
the governing equations and boundary
conditions in all their generality
and try to see so these are the
governing equations and boundary
conditions
present uh which we had obtained at the
end of
the last video at the end of the long
derivations
let me copy this and
paste it here and let's see how
[Music]
how this can be specialized to the
present case of the circular plate
so first and foremost what we have to
note is
that this particular formulation is
presented
in terms of the s n coordinate system
however a natural coordinate system
of choice for this circular plate is of
course the
r theta coordinate system that is the
polar coordinate system
and uh we know
or we can easily understand that here
the n variable that will correspond
to the r variable and
the s variable which is along the
periphery
that will correspond to r theta so i
believe
this particular mapping which i have
just written will not be difficult for
anyone to understand
all right another important uh very very
important point which considerably
simplifies
or massively simplifies rather our
problem or problem solution
is the fact is to notice that this is a
uniformly distributed load
it's a perfectly clamped boundary all
around
which makes this particular problem to
be perfectly
axis symmetric it is extremely extremely
important to note this
it's an axis symmetric problem
and as we have seen a number of times
earlier
especially during our course on applied
elasticity
that such considerations of axis
symmetry
can significantly reduce the complexity
of
the equations at hand for example
this equation which involves the by
harmonic
of the w deflection uh that is
considerably simplified in the presence
of this
axisymmetric condition all right
now what about the boundary conditions
okay so we'll come to those governing
equations and the solutions of that
uh you see even though this is
a kind of the simplest problem
which you could possibly tackle with
classical plate theory
even then it does have its own
challenges
so so it is not that that we have
successfully derived this very general
theory all that you have to do is simply
plug in the very
plug in the various formula here and we
can
directly arrive at the solution you
still need to understand
the the the physical insights
are necessary for solving this problem
in order to go ahead
okay so what are those things
first and foremost first and foremost we
have to note
uh which of these boundary conditions
are applicable
now that is one of the easiest questions
uh at least physically speaking
uh because we note that when you have a
clamped periphery
all around the periphery you are sure
that the deflection has to be equal to
zero
so from this condition
we know that w is specified all around
the periphery
so if this circular plate has a radius
of capital r so we can immediately say
that at r equal to
capital r w
is equal to zero next
we also know uh that
because this is a clam periphery the
slope there will also be
zero the slope there being zero means
that it is this condition
the del w del n which is specified
or it is 0. so not only
this w is equal to 0 here
but we also have that del w
del n which is equivalent to
del w del r because you note that
this n variable it maps to r
that is equal to zero all along the
periphery
now this certainly makes us happy okay
that we have
successfully uh modeled the given
uh boundary condition this clamp
boundary condition
in terms of these these boundary
conditions
that that came about as a result of a
long derivation of the classical plate
theory
but there is a point of concern here
and that concern is you see
if we if we write down this this
governing equation
if we write down this governing equation
it is a fourth order equation
okay no matter what form it takes no
matter what simplifications are
available to us
as a result of this access symmetry it
is still a fourth order differential
equation
now that fourth order differential
equation can be solved completely
only if we have four boundary conditions
or four conditions to
solve for the unknown constants but here
we have written only
two conditions okay so what is the
missing
what is missing here so we have to
understand that
some conditions need to be specified at
r equal to zero
also okay and what is it that motivates
us
to think specifically about the point r
equal to zero
so we can we can uh we can understand
that motivation
uh only if we if we take up this
governing equation
and try to see its form well
uh it's like this our governing equation
is this okay and we wish to write
this by harmonic of w
in terms of the
of this r and r theta uh very r and
theta variables
but at the same time you note that
all derivatives with respect to theta
they will be zero because of this axis
symmetric condition so anything which
involves the del del theta or perhaps
even del square del theta square
all those things will be zero now
we also know that
this operator by harmonic operator
this can be equivalently written as the
laplacian
of the laplacian and what is this
laplacian
so uh
if we refer back to our discussions of
applied elasticity
we'll see that this laplacian
it came about as 1 by r
ddr of r
uh if we write this w here
it's like this
okay so uh we'll have to do this del
square
of this del square of w up
and uh this is they should be quite
familiar to you
uh if you go back to the notes of
applied elasticity where we dealt with
the by harmonic not of the w but of the
air stress function back then
okay so in terms of the mathematical
form that it takes
it is absolutely the same
now if we i mean no matter what what
that is specif specific form is
you understand that it is involving this
derivative with respect to r and what is
the
domain of this r this r is going from
0 to capital r okay you understand here
that our r here
it goes from 0 to capital r
so we already have specified uh so we
have our governing equation in terms of
the derivatives of r
so that is our independent variable and
that independent variable is going from
0 to r and we have already specified
boundary conditions in
at small r equal to capital r so all
that we have to
write or what is missing from our
framework is
the condition which should be written or
r
equal to 0 that is at the center of the
plate and that is the motivation here
for considering
some conditions which could be written
at the center of the plate that is at r
equal to zero
question is what are those conditions
well
uh
think about it okay so
can we directly say can we directly say
that at r equal to zero uh
we know w can we say that
well certainly not we cannot say that w
is going to be 0
in fact if you just think about this
physical problem you will realize that
what is actually going to happen is that
r at r equal to 0
w is actually going to take the maximum
value
okay but
one thing is sure that w at r equal to
zero
should be a finite value it may take on
a maximum value
but it should be a finite value and is
that condition of finiteness of w
which will be actually helpful to us why
we are specifically
seeking this finiteness will be clear to
us
once we have the solution form for this
del for w equal to q and we look at that
the other condition which we'll again
look at
is so we have three conditions in our
hand graph
the fourth condition that we are going
to use is
the is the fact that the moment uh
that has to be finite there also okay
so why again we are talking about the
moment that again will be clear to us
once we have this solution form for this
w so
the first thing that we have to do going
forward is to
seek a solution form for this d delta
for w
is equal to q equation considering these
things
okay so
so i have this del square w is equal to
q
[Music]
and that will be written like 1 by r
ddr
r dtr
so now i am going to repeat this
laplacian again
you see whatever is present within this
curly bracket here
that is the laplacian of w
and whatever is present outside that is
the the outside laplacian operator so
that is this laplacian and
inside inside this curly bracket i have
written this l square w
okay so we have to solve this and let us
not forget
that we do have this d also present
and forgive me they should be at
4.
so there is a d present here
now what we are going to do is to set
q which is a given constant divided by d
which is another constant that
as a special value
64 beta now this seems like a rather
uh mischievous trick and it is
a little bit mischievous in the sense
but it's very clever
in the sense that if you keep on doing
this integration which you'll have to do
eventually
because of this number of
integrations you will keep on obtaining
various denominators
as the integrations pile up and in order
to
not have ugly fractions at the end
this kind of a 64 comes in rather handy
you can absolutely put this as just a
constant k
or some beta it doesn't matter but if
you take the 64 here
ultimately those um the rather large
numbers in the denominator
they cancel out okay and this is
actually a trick which is present
in the book of uh elasticity
by lando and lipschitz uh that famous uh
series which is part of the that book is
part of the famous series on
uh theoretical physics it's famous on
the world over
we'll be referring to some of the
examples from there okay
so if you do this and proceed okay if
you keep on doing the integrations
uh and and i encourage you to to do that
by
with your own hand at least once in your
life uh
or if you're feeling a little bit lazy
you can
take access to a symbolic python in
jupiter notebook
whatever way you do it once so
ultimately what you will be
obtaining for the solution of the
solution form of w please note that this
is not the final solution
will be obtaining it uh like this beta r
to the power 4
plus a r squared ln
r plus b
lnr plus c
r square d okay and please note that i
have not played any special trick to
genetically go from here to here
i have actually done this solution
myself beforehand and i'm just
copying it and writing it here but i
encourage you to please do it okay
so please arrive please arrive at this
solution form yourself
i'm not doing it i'm not investing any
time on this because
it just involves some calculus and
algebra
which most of you are expert at
uh rather i'd like to invest the time
present in this video
uh to actually do some serious
and discussions associated with the
physical uh
of the geometrical conditions associated
with this problem
okay so uh
you see now that we have the solution
form
uh i'll copy this in the next page uh
you see
this form it contains the logarithmic
terms
if it has a r square l and r it also has
an ln
okay so the discussion that we
that we have that we have to do with
respect to this w
is finite is reminiscent of things
which we did in our undergraduate days
in our
courses on heat transfer those heat
conduction problems
and also those kinds of finite
conditions conditions associated with
the finiteness of the solution
those were also applicable when dealing
with
uh positive flows uh some people say it
like poisoning flows
uh uh anyway so back in fluid mechanics
that
and as well as in heat transfer those
were some of the places
where we had even in our undergraduate
days uh
utilize the condition of the finiteness
of the solution
to to impose certain restrictions
on these constants now please note that
immediately by saying that at r
equal to zero
the solution should be finite we require
that b should be equal to zero
so
at r equal to 0 w
should be finite this is what we say
this is the first condition we actually
impose so this
itself acts like a boundary condition at
r equal to zero
w should be finite and this implies
that b must be zero
from this term okay blnr please note
that i also have this logarithmic term
here
but it is multiplied by this r square
now you note that as r
tends to zero although
the ln r term that tends to minus
infinity
which is something which would make the
uh the w to be
infinite but at the same time
we have this r squared term so this r
square
term uh that itself tends to zero so we
have
the form as r tends to zero uh as
zero times infinity or it can be written
like
a 0 divided by 0 form or an infinity by
infinity form
so there is some hope perhaps that this
term
could perhaps contribute
potentially to some finite value of w we
are not sure
okay so we'll have to seek another
condition
uh to see what what what is the fate of
this
a and the condition which will impose
there
is to say that the moment at the center
that also needs to be finite if
now
let's see there is a challenge here
actually
okay so it is one thing to say
that the moment is zero but what is the
form of the moment itself
that we don't know that we have not
derived
so let me go to the next page
and just write down the expression of
the moment
and when i say the moment i mean this
moment so this
basically corresponds to m n
okay what we had obtained as m n this is
the
uh part uh associated with that so this
is the mr associate
or a correspond to that that mn now this
mr
it takes the form this let me write that
down and then i'll have a discussion
d square w d r square plus nu
by r d
w d r where you please note that this
new
is the poisons ratio and this new is the
same thing which is
actually present within the the
definition
of the coefficient d itself okay
now how did we arrive at this
well uh this is actually part of
uh or it is actually one of the problems
in the problem sheet number three
so people who are watching this video
and who are enrolled
in this course of advanced mechanics of
solids
i will have an opportunity to to do this
problem officially
uh i'll i'll post a link
to the problem sheet uh in the
description of this video also
uh so people who are not enrolled in
this course may take a look
up and for people who are enrolled in
this course if you have any doubts we
can always discuss it in the live
session
uh but let me just give it a give a hint
here
that this mr it can be obtained
from the general expression of mn
that mn can be represented in terms
of the coset and sine theta but there is
a direct route
of going from the x
y coordinate system to the r and that we
have already
i mean we know the the recipe of doing
that
from our studies uh in applied
elasticity in the previous semester
uh again for the reference of those
who are not enrolled in this course and
watching this video
there's a separate playlist on applied
elasticity i'll put the link of that in
the description of this video also
so i mean detailed discussions
in going from the x y coordinate system
to the r theta coordinate system were
done
in the course on applied elasticity
rather easy to do
once we know what to do uh using
symbolic python
so i will not invest any more time
beyond this hints
rather i'll go ahead and try to utilize
this
this information here okay now
uh what i'll do is let me paste this
thing
is the solution the solution form
now uh this part
this much i will do so uh
dwtr
that is for beta r cube
plus twice a r
ln r plus a r
plus b by r
but you note that this b has been
already set to zero so we might not as
well
consider it and then we have this twice
cr
then this is a constant next for d
square w d r square
we have 12 beta r
square plus twice a
ln r plus
twice a plus a
minus b by r square
and of course this is twice c so
uh i mean i might as well cancel these
terms b
zero
so i have to go back to this expression
of mr
and uh do this thing actually okay now
what i'll do is
i'll play a little trick here and
instead of writing this within the whole
bracket
it's only going to clutter it up i'll do
this
mr divided by e
okay so i'm free to write these terms
nicely this is
for beta our
plus twice a
are uh
pardon me i should be first writing this
this is plus 3a that's twice c
so that is my d squared w d r squared
plus uh i need to write this nu by
r so i'll do that operation
in one shot i'll divide throughout by r
for this expression
that will give me 4 beta r square plus
twice a ln r
plus a plus
yc okay
so this is basically my mr expression
and i need
so what we had said was that at r equal
to zero
mr should be finite
now you see what is the benefit okay so
it's like a
posteriori realization of the benefit of
this
taking this thing so if we say that mr
should be finite
we can actually impose a condition on
this a
because you see just like previously
the term involving the b was left with
just the
lnr term at the lnr term so now also
this a
has this coefficient l and r you forget
about the rest of it
okay if you consider this term here this
here is a
and you note here the other lnr term
that also has
the a in front of it you can't say
anything about this given poissons ratio
2 is just 2.
so the implication here
is that a must be 0
because if a is not 0 then this ln
r here and this lnr here is going to
make this
mr to be tending to infinity
and that is not acceptable so a must be
zero
so we have a situation which is
considerably simplified
w here now is uh
we don't have to deal with this b term
we don't have to deal with this
a term so therefore our w
is beta r to the power 4
plus c r square plus d
okay so let me copy this and go to the
next page
now we can utilize
the boundary conditions which were which
we had written down
at all sorry about that
we can utilize the boundary conditions
which we had written
at r equal to capital r
okay so
at r equal to r
we have w is equal to 0 which
implies beta r
to the power 4 plus c r square
plus d is equal to 0
and also at r equal to
r we had d w
d r is equal to zero uh let's not forget
that we have already obtained the
expression for d w d r
in this page so i can just utilize it
from here
you also note that this a is 0 this a is
0
and here the only thing and this
small r is of course capita can be
replaced by this capital
r
so what we have for c is that
c is equal to minus twice
beta r squared and the moment we have
the c
we can go back to this equation
and write it
c can be replaced by this twice beta r
square so this is twice
beta r to the power 4 minus beta r to
the power
4 so that is just beta r to the power 4
so finally what we have is
w is equal to
[Music]
beta small r to the power 4 plus
for c what we are going to do is
uh write this thing twice beta
capital r square let's not forget the
small r square which is present here
and for this small d i have this beta r
to the power 4
and please note that this is a very nice
form
because this is simply r square
minus r square
whole square okay you can check you can
take d
com beta common this is r4 minus
twice small r square capital r square
plus
r4 so that is just this form
all right so this is our solution and
and uh if you just
wish to write this this is
q by t and uh this is
this comes with a 64 let's not forget
that
so this is our solution okay nice clean
solution
and uh as expected uh this takes on a
very nice axis symmetric form also
and you can actually check that the w is
going to be maximum
at uh r equal to zero
okay now uh even with the simplest of
setup
uh you see that we had to content with
with at least a couple of difficulties
and later on when we address
problems involving the simply supported
condition at the periphery
the things will be slightly more
complicated okay
but nevertheless it is uh possible to
obtain um
solutions uh for those uh situations
also
all right on that note i will end this
video thank you very much